quoi vous paraît que vous avez une
surprise pour pour moi encore si c'est
ce qu'on dit je ne sais pas surprise
pour vous ah oui non ah oui ah bah si
c'est oui parce qu'il était le meilleur
quand il est avec toi et pas du tout à
l'heure j'ai tenté de venir chez vous
oui et je n'ai pas réussi puisque c'est
chez moi j'ai retrouvé des dvd beaucoup
d'animaux d'ailleurs ça sent pas bon du
tout chez moi et par est d'accord oui il
ya donc une autre porte parce que je
pense avoir vraiment un
et là je ne crois pas du tout à ce que
je veux dire je pense avoir trouvé
vraiment votre domicile voile alors là
c'est là ils m'ont dit il m'a dit
l'aînée monde il a une surprise pour un
chroniqueur a alors on m'aura pas
informés c'est ça c'est moi non non
c'est chez moi non du montage là c'est
le panneau la photo là c'est ma porte
sur ce que c'est matthieu delormeau
cabinda c'est votre appart
[Musique]
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
johnny
[Applaudissements]
attention marbre merde la salle nemo ses
choix ouais allez allez allez dans la
salle de repas dans la salle de bain non
allez dans la salle de bal et laissé son
nom à jamais dans la salle de baba
spartoo a maintenant quelle heure il est
pas dans la salle sur balles et merci dd
volée ratée repas du sénégal à la voile
à paris
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
dans la chambre de mathieu n'était pas
un coup sûr dans son émotion à dire
chambres au décor du succès mois encore
[Musique]
ah ah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ils ont prouvé à tous les tiroirs
c'est vrai quoi avoir un bébé quoi y
aller que les soirées sont bonnes pour
aller battre